so what inspired you to do this I start
walking across America because I wanted
to be somebody else proud of you know if
somebody said to me who's your hero or
who inspires you I want to be able to
look them in the eye say me completing
it that's certainly part of it yeah you
know out there yet to have a no matter
what you know clause in that contract
with yourself because you do something
like that things can and will it
definitely go wrong over that time
period I heard you had a scary incident
that happened yeah well I was about not
even halfway I was in eastern Colorado
it's a very flat part of Colorado and I
came out of our support vehicle and um I
got bit by a rattlesnake and which is
deadly yeah if you don't get to the
hospital in time it can kill most people
know where I was definitively in the
middle of nowhere okay
basically yeah I was thirty miles from
the last time I 60 miles from the next
town oh my gosh yes I was a few days
later taught my beat look when I was
pregnant
that's real I didn't have to walk
anywhere it just happened how long did
it take you to recover from that it took
me about three weeks so I went from
doing you know 24 miles a day down to
zero so I just you know start bill my
way up from the bathroom then they let
me go home so I you use the walker to
get to the kitchen and eventually I was
walking down the street and then one
mile at two miles and you picked it
right back up I went I had to go back to
the the st. spot where I got bit to
finish my journey you just start with
the middle finger like take that snake
I was actually pretty scared to go back
I didn't want to go back there but I
knew I have made this commitment to
myself and like I said I was doing that
to be somebody I was actually proud of
and somebody I was actually proud of
that person hasn't quit you know and
that feeling you got to Venice Beach
[Applause]
first of all let's start walking if I
get a waist like that okay
Mama's gonna be walking all day all
night okay like how was it being on the
beach that was pretty cool you finished
it you definitely one of the best
moments of my life for sure to make it
there but at the same time even though I
finished my my walk across America I'm
not done you know I had an inkling
before I left that there was more inside
me and what I found out was I was
actually wrong is like not just a little
bit more like way more and so even
though my walk is over my journey is not
and I'm not particularly interested in
becoming like old fat dude who says you
remember at one time I did something
cool I don't want to be that guy I don't
even really want to meet that guy I've
no interest in them so you should make
another album and 5 million steps
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my bucket list was to meet a man who has
walked 2,500 miles also to dance backup
one day for Beyonce yeah you're a
Houston girl - oh he is - yes that's
right and I just want to witness those
quads in person that's all I'm telling
it you tell Beyonce get billions of
views you'll be in the next video yeah I
don't know if I'd want to dance next to
Beyonce unless it was a comedy I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my YouTube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this